🐯 Sound Hodori 사운드 호돌이 サウンド ホドリ
God, we come before you tonight with words that fail,
but hearts and bodies that are present to you, God.
God, we stand on the truth of your promises,
that you are the source of hope,
the source of peace that surpasses understanding,
the source of comfort in our grief and anger and rage.
And God, we remember that we are all connected,
that we all are part of your kingdom,
so we lift each other up.
We hurt together, we lift each other up together,
we love one another with all that we have.
So God, help us to be anchored in your hope,
to have faith for what is yet unseen,
to live in and lean into your promises
that all will be free,
that every tear will be wiped.
God, thank you that through it all,
you are still faithful and you are still good.
And we thank you for that.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Would you guys stand with us as we sing Amen together?
Amen. Amen. Amen. Amen.
Let's make that our prayer. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Hope, falling down like rain.
Love, that I can't explain.
Peace that stills my soul.
Light, light in the darkest place.
Life, even in the pain.
It feels like coming home.
Where the Spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom.
I am free. Amen.
Where the Spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom.
I am free. Amen.
Here, I'm alive again.
Gone is the weight of sin.
Oh, sweet liberty.
Praise God, who saved my life.
I'm born with the blood of Christ.
I have been redeemed.
Where the Spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom.
I am free. Amen.
Where the Spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom.
I am free. Amen.
Let's sing that with me one more time.
Where the Spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom.
I am free. Amen.
Made us free.
Where the Spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom.
I am free. Amen.
Sing free at last.
Free at last.
Thank God almighty,
I am free at last.
All my chains are in the past.
Thank God almighty,
I am free at last.
Put your hands together.
Free at last.
Thank God almighty,
I am free at last.
All my chains are in the past.
Thank God almighty,
I am free at last.
Free at last.
Thank God almighty,
I am free at last.
All my chains are in the past.
Thank God almighty,
I am free at last.
Oh, I'm free at last.
Where the Spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom.
I am free. Amen.
One more time.
Where the Spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom.
I am free. Amen.
Thank you, guys.
You kids are dismissed to go to your class.
Thanks for singing with us.
And we're going to move into the prayers of the people.
Would you guys read this prayer aloud with me?
For this city of Sachse, Texas,
and for every city and community
and for all of those who live in them,
we pray to you.
For the good earth that you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve it,
we pray to you.
For those who travel on land, sea, or air,
For the old and the sick,
for the widow and the orphan,
for the injured and the suffering,
we pray to you.
For the poor and oppressed,
the unemployed and destitute,
for prisoners and captives,
and for all who remember and care for them,
we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us
and that you hear us,
and so we lift these names and situations up to you.
For the families who are grieving.
Jewel.
Chelsea.
Jack.
For the names and moments that we've spoken aloud
and for those that we have kept in our hearts,
we pray to you that they may have life and light,
healing and hope,
peace and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
You are my joy.
You are my song.
You are the well,
the one I'm drawing from.
You are my refuge,
my whole life long.
Where else would I go?
Surely my God is the strength of my soul.
Your love defends me.
And when I feel like I'm all alone,
Day after day,
night after night,
I will remember
You're with me in this fight.
Although the battle,
it rages on,
the war's already won.
I know the war is already won.
Surely my God is the strength of my soul.
Your love defends me.
And when I feel like I'm all alone,
We sing Hallelujah.
You're my portion,
my salvation.
Hallelujah.
You're my portion,
my salvation.
Surely my God is the strength of my soul.
Your love defends me.
And when I feel like I'm all alone,
Surely my God is the strength of my soul.
Your love defends me.
And when I feel like I'm all alone,
We sing Hallelujah.
You're my portion,
my salvation.
Hallelujah.
You're my portion,
my salvation.
Hallelujah.
You're my portion,
my salvation.
Hallelujah.
You're my portion,
my salvation.
guitar plays softly
Therefore let everyone who is godly pray to you
while you may be found.
Surely when the mighty waters rise,
they will not reach him.
You are my hiding place.
You will protect me from trouble
and surround me with songs of deliverance.
Many are the woes of the wicked,
but the Lord's unfailing love
surrounds the man who trusts in him.
Rejoice in the Lord and be glad, you righteous,
seeing all you who are upright in heart.
guitar plays softly
How can I respond
to the love that you have lavished on me?
I don't have much,
but I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you.
guitar plays softly
Every part of me
wants to love you like you've loved me.
Lord,
every part of me
wants to love you like you've loved me.
My Lord,
I don't have much,
but I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you.
I don't have much,
but I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a life I'll give to you.
I have a life I'll give to you
I have a heart that beats for you
I don't have much
But I have a heart that beats for you
I have a heart that beats for you
I reach out and you find me in the dust
You say no amount of untruths can separate us
I reach out, I reach out and you find me in the dust
I will rejoice, I will rejoice in the simple gospel
I will rejoice in you Lord
I will rejoice in the simple gospel
I have a heart that beats for you
I don't have much
But I have a heart that beats for you
I have a heart that beats for you
God, sometimes on nights like tonight
it does feel, those words feel more real than ever
There's so much control that we don't have
There's so many things that are beyond our grasp
Beyond our understanding
So many things we can't explain or make sense of
And tonight, maybe all that we have is just a heart
that needs more of Jesus
That needs more of your light and your love
That needs more of your hope
And your freedom
And I believe that you meet us right there God
When we have nothing that we feel we have to give back
And yet you come in your goodness, your grace
And you lift us up
You lift our chin
You grieve with us
You offer hope
God, it's nights like tonight when your gospel message
seems more necessary, more powerful than anything
To forgive those who persecute
To love those who hate
To turn the other cheek
To stand with the people on the margins
To be a voice for the voiceless
To love when we feel like there's no more love to give
It is the mystery of the gospel that we need
It's the power of a redeeming God that we look to
And we stand together in this great love
We anchor ourselves into it
We weave it into the fabric of our lives
Into our relationships, into our workplaces
Into our families
Into our friendships
Great love that lays down its life
We trust in that tonight
And you keep drawing us forward, God
Will you be our light in the very darkest of places?
Would you be our strength and our song?
Our refuge
In Jesus' name, amen
Amen
All right, well, good evening.
Grace and peace, it's really, really good to be with you all.
And as we've been, as Karen mentioned, as we've been singing,
there's something really, I think, beautiful about coming together
in times and seasons like this.
And I think there's always the, just the temptation
in whether you find yourself really grieving over the shooting
or just for various reasons.
I mean, I'm in touch with many of you via text throughout the week
and I know there's just so many battles and so many struggles.
You know, like life is often a lot of pain.
That's life.
And so I think there's something so beautiful
about coming together in the midst of it, right?
Instead of finding that kind of lamenting and suffering and pain
kind of driving us, like the temptation is that it drives us into isolation.
You know, it's like we start getting in that depressed state,
even though we know what we need is like connection,
but boy, we're not feeling it.
Just so not feeling it.
You know what I mean?
We just kind of want to like hermit away,
even though that just sends us into like the worst of spirals.
So I just love that we can come together
and be with each other in the midst of, yeah, whatever you're facing.
So with that in mind, I want to just welcome you all again.
Thank you for being here.
And as always, that includes those joining us online
and also anyone who's new to the community,
thank you for having the bravery to come through those doors
and into strange people, strange faces you've never seen.
And we're just really, really grateful that you're here.
So we have been in a series,
and this is actually the fourth and the final part of our series
titled Stranger Things When the Bible Gets Weird.
And because next week is Advent, which is kind of hard to believe,
but like it's the season of preparation for the birth of Christ.
And it's always the Sunday after Thanksgiving,
which, by the way, Thanksgiving's coming up.
So, you know, if you're not like on top of that, start thinking.
You know, it's always these things always catch me off guard.
Like, oh, my gosh, it's Thanksgiving.
So that'll be into next Sunday.
We'll get into Advent.
So wrapping up the series tonight,
and the title of the message is Mysterious Bodies.
Mysterious Bodies.
And the passage tonight is a little bit different.
If you've been here for the series, you know, we've been looking at stories.
Some of them, like some of them just have been a little bit strange or weird.
Something like Jonah and the Whale was one we looked at a few weeks back,
where this prophet of God is swallowed by what the Bible calls a great fish.
So we kind of unpack that story.
And so sometimes it's stories like that where it's just sort of like strange.
Others have been like sort of morally problematic,
like the one we looked at last week, the story of the prophet Elisha
and calling down a bear attack upon some youth.
And so that's sort of, you know, weird and strange for a different reason.
So I would say the one tonight, this might be kind of unique among them all.
A, it's from the New Testament.
B, it's actually the words of Christ himself.
And C, it's actually a verse that I quote, if not verbatim,
I at least allude to it every single week
because it's part of our communion liturgy.
And so because of that, you know, it's one of those passages
that probably it just may not strike you as strange.
And thus like, well, why is this in a series called Stranger Things?
This isn't weird.
Although I want us to kind of read it again for the first time.
You know, sometimes familiarity with a passage can just, I don't know,
it's like the words are being said,
but they're not hitting us as they might have, right, at first.
And so let me go ahead and read it.
This is from Matthew 26, verse 26, which says,
While they were eating, Jesus took bread,
and when he'd given thanks, he broke it,
and he gave it to his disciples, saying,
Take and eat, this is my body.
That's a strange phrase, isn't it?
Like, this is my body, that's the key line for tonight.
This is my body.
I mean, is there, again, maybe you're so familiar with it,
you're just kind of like, oh yeah, of course, that's my body.
But I'm guessing at some point maybe this struck you as a little strange.
Maybe not, I don't know, maybe just quickly you're like,
well, he means it poetically, you know.
But it's an interesting little turn of phrase.
And I mean, I think at like a very literal level,
like if I were not a Christian and hearing this for the first time,
I think my first thought would honestly be just like,
no, it's not.
It's not your body, that's bread.
You're Jesus, and just not.
I don't know, maybe you mean it in some other sense or something,
but you're just, it's not, it's not your body.
It's bread, fat bread.
So it is, it's a strange little turn of phrase.
And I think the kind of question that I want driving the message tonight,
and as I get into that I should name that I've been,
last week I was drawing from Jonathan Paggio,
Eastern Orthodox Christian thinker.
This week it's from someone named Graham Ward
in his book Cities of God, where he got me thinking about this passage
in a new way, and thus I was like,
oh, I must include this in the Stranger Things series.
His book, oh, I said it, Cities of God.
It's just wonderful.
But he asks this question, which really caught me off guard.
He said, well, what if Jesus is right?
And it was strange, because I think probably it's my Protestantism.
If you know, there's like a whole history and theological history
to this statement, this is my body,
and there's Protestants and Catholics and kind of diverge ways
in interpreting this.
But it caught me off guard.
And kind of the thing I want to maybe push us to really consider
is like what if we think Jesus is wrong
because we are making certain assumptions,
certain kind of Western, some cultural assumptions
about what bodies are
that we don't even realize we're making those assumptions.
Does that make sense?
It's sort of like the old saying about, you know,
like one fish swimming by another fish,
and the older fish says to the younger fish,
hey, morning, how's the water?
And then the younger fish says, what's water?
And the idea being, right, a fish doesn't even know it's in water
because that's called life.
You know what I mean?
In essence, it's so close to it, it's been there from the beginning
that it's just, it's not even a thing.
It's the thing that makes all other things possible.
It's sort of like having a pair, another metaphor would be like lenses,
like where you put on a pair of lenses and you're seen through the lenses.
But if you had just worn glasses from the very beginning,
you might forget, in fact, some of us do,
like forget that we're even wearing glasses.
In essence, you could think of that as like interpretations,
cultural assumptions, or like lenses that we put on
and we're seen through them, but we don't even realize we're doing it.
And I wonder if that's some of what's happening here.
And it really centers around what bodies are.
And by bodies, I mean this in a very diverse sense,
like whether we're talking about the body of, say, like a rock,
or the body of a flower, or the body of a piece of bread,
or the body of a human being.
For us, a body would be something like this,
kind of as like a simplistic definition,
like a body is like the visible structure of a thing.
Right? It's kind of simple enough, straightforward.
I'm like, yeah, that's what a body is.
And kind of built into this assumption
is that bodies are quite separate from one another.
Right? Because if you have like a rock and a flower
and a piece of bread and a human being,
those bodies, those are, you know, separate bodies.
To use kind of more academic language, you might say
bodies are like autonomous, kind of self-defined,
self-enclosed things.
In other words, you know, like I'm over here
and you all are over there, and we are separate bodies.
Right? This is sort of how we tend to think of things.
And inherent in that is that we don't think
there's anything really connecting us.
Right? Because of the separation, we are separate bodies.
And, in fact, if we kind of start to say,
well, actually, these bodies are more connected
than you might realize, well, then we call that woo-woo.
Right? We say, no, I don't really go in for woo-woo.
I just, you know, I'm an American.
It's obvious.
But what's interesting is that's not really necessarily
how the Bible seems to think of bodies,
how specifically the New Testament,
and really more specifically the Gospels,
tends to think about bodies.
And it doesn't seem to be what Jesus,
how he seemed to think about bodies.
And, you know, honestly, even, like I'm far from a, you know,
scientist or quantum physicist or whatever,
but just from the little I've picked up,
even it seems like science, from what I can tell,
is starting itself to get a little spooked.
You know, even science is starting to sound a little woo-woo,
you know, if you know anything about, like,
quantum mechanics and such.
Like, even everything out here that feels just so solid.
You know, there's a body just, that's a body right there.
You can't even hear it.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's not connected to anything.
And yet, if you go down into, like, the subatomic level,
it's actually mostly empty space and moving parts.
And some scientists would even say
it's maybe better described as, like, energy,
which starts, you know, all of a sudden,
your quantum, your physicist,
like, starting to sound a little woo-woo, you know.
It's like, okay.
And then actually maybe some of those particles
are somehow, like, connected to other things,
such as they've done little experiments.
You know, when you touch this one,
like, you split the atom,
and then you touch it over here,
and this one's moving,
even though they're supposed to be separate.
But somehow they're not.
And they're like, oh, gosh.
Oh, gosh.
We don't know how this is happening.
Right?
So it's getting a little spooked out there.
But the point is that in the gospel specifically,
bodies are not separate, self-defined,
self-enclosed things.
Instead, bodies constantly commune.
Bodies pass through.
Bodies share.
And bodies can expand to include one another.
In other words, bodies are much stranger,
more wonderful, more mysterious things
than we tend to imagine.
And I think, you know, we might ask,
well, how's that possible?
I think it's because matter is not all that matters.
In other words, matter is infused,
enfolded, and upheld by God's spirit.
In other words, everything that is,
the visible world, things arise from God's spirit
and in every moment are sustained by God's spirit
such that a certain connection through God
actually remains.
This is what Gregory of Nyssa,
the church father writing 1,500 years ago,
he called it God's, all things are sustained,
upheld, enfolded by God's divine energy,
which is sounding a little woo,
but also like those, you know,
some of those modern scientists
where there's this energetic connection.
Perhaps I might be losing you at this point.
You're like, oh, this is all very deep.
Let me give like a metaphor.
There's a wonderful book called
The Hidden Life of Trees.
And Mindy earlier, my sister-in-law,
she said this is such a Brett example.
Like, who else would read this book?
Like, well, it's so cool.
I know, nerd, nerdy, nerdy.
But in this book, it's really fascinating
because, of course, when you look at trees,
right, at the surface, the world of appearance,
you know, what you can see,
they just look so separate, don't they?
Tree here, tree there, tree there, tree there.
And maybe another leaf's touch or something, you know.
But outside of that, like, they're separate.
But what are ecologists learning
that actually beneath the surface,
their roots are intertwining
and they are communicating
and they are even co-sharing?
Do you know this?
Trees share nutrients with one another.
Like, if this one's in need,
it can like send nutrients.
Like, what?
They are co-evolving.
They are co-growing.
And so while on the surface, right,
it looks like, what, separate trees.
That's how bodies are.
They're all just separate things, you know.
But I think this is a perfect picture
of really what kind of the New Testament's hinting at
about not just, you know, trees,
but really all bodies,
that beneath what we can see,
there is a connection, right?
So while we think you got a person here
and a person there
and a dog over there
and a flower over here
and they look so separate,
but at the unseen level,
the level of spirit,
there's a profound connection.
And why is that?
Again, because the material world
arises from the spiritual world.
And so there, a connection remains.
Another example that would be
more human-like is,
did you all know,
so here you are all sitting,
and unless you have your significant other,
you're probably not touching.
That would be a little strange,
like someone just randomly like, hey.
And yet, did you know,
even as you all sit there
looking like such separate bodies,
did you know that this whole time
your bodies have been tuning into one another?
Like you have, for example,
pheromones have been passing.
And even there's something called limbic resonance,
which is a really weird idea.
It's basically this idea that
your brain tunes into,
picks up on the kind of mind attunement of others,
the moods, the emotional kind of tenor
of other minds,
and you attune yourself to them.
You sync up with them.
This is why, for example,
you might walk through those doors
and feel massively depressed.
And then ever so subtly,
you come here,
and even if you never say a word to anyone,
you just start feeling better.
What's happening there?
Your bodies are amazing.
Your bodies are more than you think.
You don't walk in these doors,
and you're not just some autonomous,
self-defined, self-enclosed thing
choosing occasionally to speak a word and connect.
No, no, no.
Your bodies are always already
tuning in to one another.
So, let's go ahead and return to Christ.
And let's talk about His body.
We could talk about all sorts of things.
We could talk about the miracles He did
with His body, right?
And with bodies,
things with multiplying the body of bread
and feeding people or healing human bodies and such.
We could talk about the fascinating nature
of His resurrected body.
He could pass through walls
or appear to people such that they
at first couldn't recognize Him,
but then suddenly they could recognize Him.
And there's all sorts of weird, mysterious things
about Christ's resurrected body.
All sorts of things.
But above all,
what I want to focus in on
is the capacity of Christ's body
to expand and to include other bodies.
I think above all things,
this is like the strangest, most wonderful idea.
Now, key to this is what's known as the ascension.
And Graham Ward points out,
after the resurrection,
you have the ascension of Jesus.
And this isn't about Jesus disappearing.
Like it's like, oh no, Jesus, you're gone.
Instead, Christ ascends
so that His body can begin to fill all things.
And this becomes really key.
So He ascends so that His body can expand
and He can make good on His promise in Matthew 18-20.
Maybe you've read this passage
and it has never made sense to you,
but it says this,
For where two or three gather in My name,
there am I with them.
This is about the expansion of Christ's body.
And again, at one level, we might think,
what, no, that's impossible.
This isn't how bodies work.
But what if we're wrong?
And what if Jesus is right?
He ascends and His body expands
so that He can, coming back to our original text,
Matthew 26-26, make good on His promise.
Take and eat, this is My body.
He ascends so that,
as Ephesians 1-22-23 names,
Christ's body can envelop the body of the church
such that we call the church the what of Christ?
The body of Christ.
I mean, this is,
think of that,
Christ's body has now expanded
to include each and every one of you.
This, like, this is a fascinating,
strange, beautiful idea.
Okay, so that's a lot of theology.
I want to kind of bring this back to, like,
okay, so what does this actually mean for our lives?
Let me give you four takeaways.
First, My body, your body,
is more mysterious and wonderful
than you or I have ever dreamed.
In other words, you are not just cells
and atoms and, like, dead matter.
You are a beautiful, wonderful living body
shot through with God's Spirit,
with more ability to be influenced by other bodies,
all bodies, again, not just human beings,
trees and flowers and rocks and all of it,
and with more capacity to influence others' bodies
than you might dream,
which leads to our second insight or takeaway.
I am both influencing others' bodies
and being influenced by them, by their bodies,
far more than I am aware of.
I think of the strange thing human beings do
where we go to coffee shops to work or study or read
to be alone with other people.
Isn't that a strange thing?
It's like, well, I could just be alone at my house,
but I'd rather be alone with other people.
Why?
It's all this we're talking about.
Like, there's just something about
being with other human bodies
and it just impacts us
in ways that we usually like.
This is also why, of course,
like concerts and places where you get
like tens of thousands of bodies all together,
it's just crazy what can kind of happen
because there's something really almost magical
about human bodies.
Third, I am affected even by those bodies
whom I claim to exclude.
This is an interesting insight from Graham Ward.
He writes this.
He says, that which I exclude from my body
or that which is excluded in my name
from the institutions, social circles, and such
to which I belong,
will affect me for good or for ill.
The ghettoizations and the segregation of,
and he lists all the isms,
racism or sexism or classism or ageism,
done in my name or condoned by my silence
injure me.
Notice Ward doesn't say there,
it injures them, those excluded.
Though, of course, that's like so obvious
he didn't feel the need to name it.
But the interesting insight is
that actually injures me.
But why on earth is this?
Because those, when I unjustly exclude someone,
I think that I'm cutting them off, right?
My body no longer has anything to do with their body.
But because of the mysterious, magical nature of bodies,
actually a connection remains.
No matter how kind of distorted
or marred that connection is.
In fact, I think our last series we did, Unclean,
I think is really deepened by all of this insight
about bodies and the nature of what bodies actually are.
Fourth and finally,
growing in Christ is an act of expansion.
Expanding my body to include, love, relate to,
and commune with all other bodies.
Again, Gregory of Nyssa, writing many moons ago,
he says,
Participation in the divine good is such that
where it occurs, it makes the participant
ever greater and more spacious than before.
Brings to it, that would be you and I,
an increase in size and strength in such wise
that the participant nourished in this way
never stops growing and keeps getting larger and larger.
He's not talking about body building.
Instead, he's talking,
well, he's saying one way to think of your life in Christ
and of your wonderful body
is that it is always either expanding
or it is shrinking.
And I think of, in other words,
our bodies are either becoming more spacious,
growing, expanding,
to include everything and everyone
from people to trees to rocks to flowers to human beings,
or we are shrinking down.
I think, for example, of like an addict
and what's happened with an addict.
Their whole world has shrunk down to their body
and the body of their drug.
And that's like the limit of their world.
They are a shrinking self.
But on the opposite end of that spectrum
is like kind of someone like the spiritual person
or a follower of Christ who's journeyed far in that.
What happens?
Our body grows and expands to include all things.
I think of, for example, I'll close with this.
Some of us went to the Sinner Peace Conference
a few weeks back.
And Sinner Peace is an organization
that's helping the church have better conversations
around theology and sexuality and sexual orientation.
And it's run by a wonderful woman named Sally Gary.
And if you've ever met Sally, she is just great.
She's kind of that perfect, wonderful mixture
of kind but confident,
humble, loving, wise.
She's just the person.
You get around her and she's got that good energy.
You know what I mean?
You like her.
And what I noticed is that just like Christ's body
has sort of expanded or is in the process of expanding
to include all things,
that anyone who goes to that conference
in a sense has communed with the body of Sally Gary
even if you never spoke to her.
Again, call it the woo-woo word that you want.
Her essence, her energy, her body
has so saturated that community
that it's like, I don't know,
it's like everywhere you go,
people have just taken on the spirit of Sally Gary.
And suddenly that whole community
is more than it would have been otherwise.
More spacious, more patient,
more loving, more kind, more humble.
What's happened?
Just like Christ, Sally Gary has expanded
and filled a community.
And I think the same is true for each and every one of us
or can be true,
that you and I are more than just cells
but instead we are called to grow,
to expand, to make room for people.
And so my prayer is that may your body become large
and like Christ fill all things and all people.
So as we come to the table of the Lord tonight,
I hope that it takes on just a bit more of a rich meaning
where instead of being only a metaphor
or only a symbol,
it becomes more than that.
Where we actually start to trust
that Christ's body is present to us
in bread and in wine.
And that as we take in Christ and consume him,
that somehow he's taking us in.
And maybe even in a good way kind of breaking us open
and then giving us to a very, very needy world.
So we practice here at the table what's called an open table.
Meaning if you're here tonight and you want to participate,
then you are free to do that.
And the way we'll come forward
is we'll start with these kind of front rows
and we'll just work our way back
so we don't get a super long line.
And then finally you're just free to partake of the elements
whenever you'd like, whether it's immediately
or you can go back to your chair and sit down.
So let me invite you to the table.
This is a Celtic Christian invitation.
This is the table, not of the church, but of the Lord.
And it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more.
So come.
You who have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often
and you who have not been here long.
You who have tried to follow and you who have failed.
Come.
Because it's the Lord himself who invites you.
And it's his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here.
Come to the table.
Come.
I love what, um, Karin said.
As we were starting our service,
she referred to something, um,
said something to the effect of,
we're not really free until all of us are free.
And, um, that has stuck with me all week.
We had a call earlier in the week
when we were planning out this service
and talking about Trans Remembrance Day,
and, um, and she said that phrase.
And it just has been going through my head
as I practiced the worship set,
as I was thinking about being together today
with all of you, and, um,
just how strangely interconnected
I have come to feel with this community.
And just, um,
you know, I carry you guys in my heart.
And, um, knowing that
when tragedies happen, um,
in our community or outside of our community
and people are impacted by it,
we carry you guys with us.
You know, you're like this unseen member,
um, in my life as I go throughout my day
or as I plan a worship set
or, you know, whatever's going on.
And, um, we were trying to think of a song
to finish with tonight.
And this song that, we've done it once before
when we talked about some racial equality
and, um, and the words just seem so fitting.
Um, any time that we're facing a situation
where there's a group of people
who are not experiencing the freedom that they should,
this song comes to mind.
And as we sing it today, um,
I just hope that, like, in my head,
I see us like there are no aisles, you know,
we're all like kumbayaing together.
There are lights, like a concert.
You know what I mean?
This is like, in my head,
this is this moment of, like, unity and togetherness
where we're holding up each other's arms.
You know what I mean?
Because some of us are feeling heavier than others.
Some of us are feeling the effects
of what's going on more than the rest.
But together, we're able to hold up each other's arms,
feel it together, carry the weight together,
shoulder our burdens together.
And that's the beauty of the body of Christ.
Um, it is that interconnectedness.
So know that as we finish this time together
that you guys are, um, prayed for,
that you're loved, that you're remembered.
Um, so would you guys just stand with us?
And even if this is a song that you're unfamiliar with,
I just, I want us to stand in that posture
of, um, being there for one another,
um, carrying one another's burdens
and believing for a future hope,
for that prophetic creativity that Karen referred to earlier,
that there will be a day where every tear is dried,
where all the sins are washed away,
and we are walking in the freedom of Christ together.
♪
There's a world at war
Caught in suffering
Silent casualties
Oh God, get us peace
In these sleepless nights
I can hardly breathe
Despite brutality
I know that we'll be free
I know we'll be free
So let the light in keep us shining
Let it break into the darkness
All the love there is to see
We'll all be free
♪
In these desperate times
Love will hold us here
Love will join our hands
Teach us to have no fear
So we lay our hate down
To wash their feet
When we see our brother
We'll all be free
Let the light in keep us shining
Let it break into the darkness
All the love there is to see
We'll all be free
Let the light in keep us shining
Let it break into the darkness
All the love there is to see
We'll all be free
We are free, free
We'll be free, free
We'll all be free
We are free, free
Let the light in keep you shining
Let it break into the darkness
All the love there's left to see
We'll all be free
Let the light in keep you shining
Let it break into the darkness
All the love there's left to see
We'll all be free
Amen. So be it.
So glad you are all here tonight.
I hope that the service was healing balm to your soul.
I think it was for the kids.
That's the hope right there, those voices.
So sweet.
Remember, in just a few minutes,
Brett will lead our baptism class.
So hang around, you can meet him right up here by the communion table.
Even if you didn't RSVP...
What's going on with my mic?
Check, check.
Okay.
So even if you didn't RSVP for the baptism class
and you're interested, just make your way up here.
You are welcome to.
If you're visiting with us tonight, we would love to connect with you this week.
We promise we will not harass you.
But if you wouldn't mind filling out a visitor card,
just as you go out the back door, it's on the little itty-bitty wooden table to your right.
There's a pen there and little cards that say the table.
If you can put your name and email address or phone number,
we would love to reach out to you this week.
Also, if you're in need of prayer,
a hug, a listening ear,
I'll be in the back at the end of the service.
I would love to be there for you in that way.
And lastly,
I would love to bless you with this benediction.
And a benediction is just a blessing upon you
as you go into your week.
So you can stay standing if you're comfortable.
You can also sit. You can hold out your hands
if you'd like just in a posture to receive these words
that I believe are true for each and every one of you here
and those of you who are watching online.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day
and it's especially true
on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead
with its yet-to-be-determined highs and lows
and everything in between,
you will be filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the same desire
to extend these gifts of love and compassion
and grace to everyone you come in contact with.
Be blessed.
Be safe this week.
And we hope to see you back here next week.
Good night.
Let the light in, keep it shining
Let it break into the darkness
All the love there's just to see
We'll all be free
Let the light in, keep it shining
Let it break into the darkness
All the love there's just to see
We'll all be free